I'm bench like 225  I can do 100 pushups I just tweaked my  arm that's why I can't work out this  week I rolled my ankle that's why I  can't play basketball oh I could dunk in  high school yeah I can do a kickflip  yeah I prefer beer over sugary drinks my  shoe size is like 14 oh I've never used  a ruler to measure my penis my car is  500 horsepower yeah I know what  horsepower is nah don't really listen a  trick no I've never heard anything by  Justin Bieber I've shot a gun before  I've never seen a notebook girl my girls  is coming back no idea dude Channing  Tatum isn't even that hot I know how to  start a fire ah dude I'm not looking for  a relationship I'm texting so many girls  right now no I don't care my ex just got  married I get laid all the time dude i  hook up all the time no I don't follow  Ayesha curry on Instagram  I'm always the big spoon I hate cuddling  I always stand when I pee